[Music]
look closely
what do we all have in common
no matter what corner of the world you
live in
you need food
water
and money
half of every transaction involves money
in exchange for goods or services
stocks a loaf of bread illegal drugs
you gotta pay for it
we spend much of our lives chasing money
to make a living and accomplish our
dreams
but it's also an instrument of
destruction some might say evil driving
criminals to lie steal and even murder
the existing banking system extracts
enormous value from society and it is
parasitic in nature
money is a catalyst for the worst and
the best of human endeavor
before civilization
we created currency
fuel for wars
the path to power
champion and enemy of innovation
money is so integral to our society and
our global economy that its true nature
remains a mystery to most
this is the story of money perhaps the
end of money as we know it
no matter how fat your bank account or
how thin your wallet to us it's all cold
hard cash there are some who want to
kill it
get rid of it
burn your dollars your euros your yen
and transform every penny you have into
ones and zeroes digital currency
entrusted to the web and computers
spread across the planet
magic internet money
it's called cryptocurrency
bitcoin
invented in secret it was a gift to the
world it's not just the currency but
it's actually programmable money a
potential curse on bankers and there's
nothing that the the big banks or
politicians can do to stop it breaking
every government's grip on money supply
what the internet did for information
bitcoin is doing for money
could it be the new gold
no you have to really stretch your
imagination to infer what the intrinsic
value of bitcoin is
regulators the federal reserve the
banking system at least understand this
is a thing that they have to take
seriously
this is going to change the economic
culture
bitcoin could be a micro economic
miracle worker and it could be a
macroeconomic wrecking ball
is bitcoin the currency of the future
a godsend for criminals
or a recipe for financial disaster
if you trust your money just as it is
we have a little story to share
once upon a time there was a big party
with everyone standing around the punch
bowl drunk
politicians credited the strong economy
to their wise decisions businesses
jumped into new profitable markets
ignoring risk in fact the experts said
there was no risk
then troubling market data from minor
countries spooked the markets rumors
spread more bad news rattled housing
prices at the heart of the financial
world a major bank went insolvent
investors and businesses made a run on
the other banks demanding their cash
deposits the largest financial
institutions in the center of the modern
world were frozen
assets were seized
banks foreclosed a credit crunch
threatened the entire world economy
[Music]
and then
finally the government stepped in
the largest bank bailout ever
swift action by the head of state had
saved the day
remember
that
no you don't
it happened two thousand years ago
rome 33 a.d ground zero for the first
recorded liquidity crisis and government
bailout in
history the largest empire the world had
ever seen was brought to its knees by a
banking disaster
emperor tiberius used money from the
national treasury to bail out the
country's troubled banks and companies
history may not repeat itself but it
certainly rhymes
badly
people in power and their money have
always been at the very center of it
the story of money is as old as
civilization itself
when we lived in small tribes keeping
track of debt was easy
you owed somebody a load of firewood a
neighbor owed you a piece of meat
credits and debits were kept in your
head a mental ledger
currency is a language that allows us to
express transactional value between
people
it's a technology that's older than
the wheel it's as old as fire
when humans wanted to trade outside
their tribe or village they needed
something everyone could agree had value
something scalable
enter commodity monies
[Music]
there were many kinds but each had to
embody the same five characteristics a
commodity money is relatively scarce
easily recognizable can be cut into
smaller pieces you can substitute one
piece for another of equal value
and you can carry it around without too
much trouble
in ancient rome it was salt
the aztecs used cacao beans it was whale
teeth on fiji
yak dung in tibet
shells in africa and china
grains metal ivory rare stones leather
fish
if it had the five characteristics of
commodity money someone probably used it
as currency
and then you ask what value do these
currencies have
if you go into a primary school you'll
see children exchanging rubber bands and
tamagotchi and pokemon cards and
baseball cards and sweets and candy and
any other form of currency people invent
currency when they have no other
currency and now they're going to invent
digital currencies
but commodities that aren't durable are
a lousy store of value
a bad cacao crop or a huge new salt
discovery can throw your currency and
economy into turmoil a more stable
system was needed
about 2500 years ago the first metal
coins were minted in china
and in what is now turkey
these coins shared the same five
characteristics with commodity money but
were also very durable
in some cases coins are the only thing
left of entire civilizations
money does not originate with
governments
money arises naturally as markets begin
to develop and as people with a division
of labor realized that if i have eggs
and you have a cow we may need some
medium of exchange in order for you to
buy my eggs for me to buy your cow
coins were an objective and universal
unit of account
and they allowed people to buy and sell
goods over vast regions
the market economy was born
coins worked
but only if people trusted that the king
or emperor who issued them wasn't
cheating on the metal content using
coins also meant that an authority now
controlled the supply of your currency
money and political power were
inextricably linked
centralized
minting coins in a steady and
predictable manner allowed economic
growth and stability
the wushu coin in china retained its
value for 500 years
in constantinople the solidus lasted for
700 years
but in those times the coins didn't have
the the milled
this sort of milled edge they were flat
and what used to happen was as coins
were passing from people to people
people would cut little bits off
and in fact
some of the taxation that the kings
would do would actually be take
one-eighth of the coin off
taxes built castles and financed
military campaigns expensive hobbies
soon royal mints were substituting
cheaper metals for silver and gold this
is called debasement and europe's kings
made a habit of it
the currency of france was debased every
20 months
for 200 years
if no one can trust the gold or silver
content of your coins how can you trade
with other countries
international merchants found a solution
they recognize that one person's debt
has value
it can be traded or transferred
when those ious came from reputable
sources they could be used as a form of
money
paper money
this money was not based on hard
commodities or metal but instead on
someone's promise to pay
merchant families like the medici in
15th century florence acted as
clearinghouses for these ious
it worked like this an english trader
ordered a shipment of italian cloth from
the medici for 100 gold coins his
promise to pay the medici was put on
paper meanwhile the medici owed 100 gold
coins to another trading partner for
delivery of wine from france the parties
didn't go to the expense of transporting
and exchanging gold coins
instead the paper was transferred
everyone agreed that the paper had value
100 gold coins but only because everyone
trusted the medici as solvent middlemen
they had created a paper money machine
within a few generations they rose from
low crime to high finance
their great wealth helped fuel the
italian renaissance and elevated the
family to levels of enormous political
power the power to marry into royal
families and get elected as popes
the ties binding money to power politics
and influence now ran through church and
state
merchants had proven that creating paper
currency could be wildly profitable
goldsmiths wanted in on the action
imagine it like this if the goldsmith
had seen over a period of time that some
of the coins he was storing for people
were gathering dust the people who owned
them
don't need them right now so what if i
go and lend them out into the community
and i charge some interest on this loan
so he starts out lending some of these
gold coins and then
later he realizes actually people don't
even want the gold coins they just want
the piece of paper that says the the
gold coins are in the bank and with the
goldsmith
so i can now make a loan
with these pieces of paper
and whatever i write on a piece of paper
as long as people trust me
they'll trust the paper
and effectively the the goldsmiths and
the early day bankers
they had literally acquired the power to
print money
more and more private paper money from
merchants and banks circulated and began
to rival the crown's coins
the power inherent in controlling and
issuing money began slipping away from
the rulers
they couldn't tax or debase this new
kind of money but they had bigger
ambitions than ever with trading posts
colonies and empires that now stretched
across the globe
for centuries european countries would
take turns building massive fleets and
waging war on each other to rule the
world
[Applause]
government wanted to take the people's
money in order to finance its wars
that's essentially the history of money
money and warfare go together
war is expensive one year's income taxes
simply aren't enough kings and queens
had to borrow money against future taxes
they needed a groundbreaking financial
innovation
government bonds
the loans came from rich merchant
families and goldsmiths who by now had
become powerful financiers and bankers
sovereign debt and deficit spending had
been born
[Music]
in 1694 the bank of england was
established to fund a war against france
england's central bank was privately
owned and granted the monopoly to issue
banknotes paper that could be redeemed
for an equal amount of gold from the
government coffers
the central bank soon also managed the
entire debt of the crown
money has been a tool of sovereignty for
centuries being able to issue currency
gave you the power but it also gave the
value to that monetary supply by backing
it with the force of state
with essentially the debt of state
[Music]
when the u.s won independence from
britain the first article of the new
constitution gave congress the exclusive
right to coin money
this currency's value was tied to gold
in government vaults from 1781 until the
panic of 1907 the financial system of
the us was an economic petri dish brief
central banks state banks private banks
private currency government currency
depressions strong growth recessions
regular boom and bus cycles
the long term as far as capital is
concerned people want predictability
people want stability
from the back of that they can plan now
it's very hard to plan in the long term
with such a level of volatility
in 1913 bankers and politicians decided
that it was in the country's best
interest and theirs to have a permanent
central bank
they created the federal reserve
among its jobs expand or contract the
supply of a single national currency the
federal reserve note
the dollar was tied to gold and
strategic control of it would avoid
booms that lead to busts
at least that was the plan
then came 1929
the great depression would have a
profound effect on monetary policy
worldwide i shall ask the congress for
the one remaining instrument to meet the
crisis
fraud
executive power
soon the fed had printed nearly all the
money it legally could to pump life back
into the economy it needed gold to fire
up the mint
so in 1933 president roosevelt issued a
controversial executive order
forcing all u.s citizens to sell their
gold to the federal reserve at a fixed
price
or go to prison
the fed offered far more cash to foreign
governments for their gold
many jumped at the offer
gold flowed in and dollars spread across
the globe
[Music]
world war ii devastated nearly every
major economy
except the united states
the military and industrial juggernaut
emerged as the global financial
superpower
the dollar had become the world's most
stable and trusted currency
other countries pegged their currency to
the dollar which could still be redeemed
for gold
in fact the u.s owned more than half of
the world's gold reserves
[Music]
in the next few decades more dollars
flowed to foreign countries governments
began debasing their coins with cheaper
metals and printing more of their own
currency than they had in gold
the bond between precious metals and
paper currency was cracking
this is a 1966 50 cent piece it was the
last coin
in regular circulation in australia to
contain silver it contains 80 silver so
in 1966
this was 50 cents nowadays it's eight
dollars roughly
in silver alone
by 1966 foreign nations had had enough
of the u.s collecting gold and printing
cash
and they had more value in dollars than
the us had bullion in its vaults
they demanded gold in return for their
paper dollars
arguments about the value of the dollar
versus their currency ensued
in 1971 president nixon settled the
matter he severed united states currency
from the gold standard
i have directed secretary connelly to
suspend temporarily the convertibility
of the dollar in the gold or other
reserve assets except in amounts and
conditions determined to be in the
interest of monetary stability and in
the best interest of the united states
never again could anyone legally demand
u.s government gold in exchange for
paper dollars for better or worse the
dollar was now backed solely by the full
faith and credit of the united states
government
the wealthiest nation the world had ever
known would bet its future on a single
word trust
people have this mythology of money that
is based on very little fact uh and one
of the nice things about bitcoin is that
it forces people to start to ask
questions about the fundamentals of
money
bitcoin is an attempt uh to adopt the
advanced computerized system that we
have
the internet to resurrecting what money
used to be all about
[Music]
i think our dollar policies our monetary
policies our fiscal policies have
absolutely created a nation of debtors
not just personal debt not just
corporate debt but government debt you
have to look at those all together as
one big thing what is the wealth of the
nation well the wealth of the nation is
a gigantic hole of money that we owe to
the rest of the world that is never
going to be paid back
today the united states pays more than
400 billion dollars in interest to its
creditors every year
when a government spends more money than
it collects in taxes
it simply borrows more or it creates
more
at one time every piece of paper money
was backed by gold
remember for every twenty dollar bill
there was twenty dollars worth of gold
in the government vault
not anymore
today governments create currency by
first creating bonds or treasury bills
these bonds are sold in the market
generating funds for the government that
issued them
large banks buy us bonds to flip them
selling them to the federal reserve at a
profit this is the magic money machine
you see the fed is america's central
bank but it doesn't have any money
no cash on its balance sheets
when a bank buys a bond and takes it to
the federal reserve the fed simply says
thank you mr banker here's the principle
and some profit
new money isn't exchanged it simply
appears on the bank's accounts magic
for 100 years and counting the precise
mechanisms of these bond purchases have
remained a secret
where it gets really interesting
the federal reserve is not a government
agency
it's a private entity and its
shareholders are banks which earn a
dividend as much as 80 billion dollars
per year total are paid out to some of
the very same banks that sell the
government debt to the fed
which banks
don't even bother asking that's also a
secret
in other words the magic money machine
answers to no one
the fed also sets the bar for how much
interest you pay for a car home or
business loan
the federal reserve has been given the
impossible task of trying to run the
credit and monetary system as though we
are the soviet union
it's the central planner for the for the
key aspect of capitalism which is how
money and credit is allocated
the federal reserve on balance uh does
not help the economy on balance it hurts
the economy and it's bound to make
mistakes even with the best of
intentions
the fed is also supposed to boost
employment with low interest rates
encouraging people and businesses to buy
more goods and services
governments getting involved in money
is a good thing and it's also a bad
thing it's a good thing because
money
is the arteries of the economy the blood
supply of the economy markets are
subject to
bouts of euphoria and despair and it
makes sense for governments to
back currency and manipulate it moving
the money supply up and down is the most
powerful way to sedate that boom and
bust cycle
manipulating the supply of money has
short-term and long-term consequences
[Music]
central banks aim to create new money
carefully strategically and very very
slowly
releasing more money into the economy
causes prices to rise ideally by two
percent every year that's supposed to
foster economic growth
but two percent inflation means the
buying power of one cash dollar in your
pocket today will be 98 cents next year
and less nearly every year to come
since 1913 when the federal reserve took
over the united states dollar we've seen
that the united states dollar has
decreased in value
98
inflation is a far higher tax because on
your income you pay it just once
if inflation is 2 you're paying a 2 tax
on your net worth every single year your
net worth held in currency
so what does that mean
if you earned a dollar in 1913 you could
buy 16 loaves of bread
today a dollar barely buys you one
that's not a quaint notion of how cheap
things used to be
it's proof that the value of your cash
is slowly withering away
that one dollar invested at two percent
in 1913 would now be worth seven dollars
and 24 cents more than 600 percent
return versus a near total loss
the us dollar has gone from being worth
one dollar to now being worth about four
cents uh so that's you know 96 of its
original value and it's a direct result
of government control
governments don't create money from thin
air all alone
you play a key role in the magic money
machine
it's not really the central banks that
are the problem and they're part of the
problem but the real problem is that
we've given the power to create money
to the same banks that caused the
financial crisis
we put our paychecks and savings into a
bank account and draw from it as we need
it the banks are custodians of our money
right
wrong
it is now the property of the bank on
their balance sheets they can do just
about anything they want with it for
example create new money
here's how
your bank account shows 100
but the bank only holds three and loans
97 to bob to buy something
in the bank's computers you still have
100 in your account but bob now has 97
of new virtual money in his account just
digits on a computer screen there's no
cash no gold or anything else backing up
the new numbers in bob's account
just his promise to pay it back
this is new money created as debt
when those 97 are spent say in a shop
the shop owner deposits into another
bank and it is let out again and again
and again and each of these people have
numbers in their accounts showing that
they own this money
so your original one hundred dollars has
multiplied now there are over three
thousand three hundred dollars in the
system
this process of loaning out far more
money than a bank actually has as cash
on hand is called fractional reserve
banking
in the uk 97
of the money that exists
is just numbers in the computer system
and those numbers are created by the
banks
banks earn untold billions in interest
every year by creating and lending
virtual money
what's more banks don't even need your
deposit to create new money if they
consider someone credit worthy for a
loan they can put new magic money into
his or her account and start charging
interest
so reporters talk about bitcoin as
though it's a as though it's the first
digital currency
but actually we use digital currency
every time you make a transaction
through internet banking or through your
your bank card
actually it's not even just digital
currency it's digital currency that is
created by the banks essentially i have
nothing
in other words all new money is debt
this is the part of money creation that
isn't taught in economics class
money in paychecks bank accounts 401ks
that loan to bob credit card debt your
home loan
all began life as virtual money created
by the banks
the entire system is based on trust
trust in the bank's solvency trust in
the debtor's ability to repay their debt
if all bank customers demanded just
three percent of their deposits right
now in cash
this run on the banks would reveal the
truth
almost none of that paper currency you
think is in your bank account exists
it never did
remember the drunken party
our financial crisis had everything to
do with virtual dollars
too many people with very little income
borrowed a lot of money they could never
repay
but the banks didn't care they didn't
have to
they quickly made and sold shaky loans
to someone else for a profit and i got
them all approved hey
fly now
selling bad loans was a good business
until the whole thing blew up in the
global financial crisis
the magic money machine destroyed 30
million real jobs
the united states alone lost 16 trillion
dollars in household wealth and the
banks foreclosed on more than one
million homes
[Music]
selling subprime loans and betting they
will fail may not be sacred
but it is lucrative
as much as one quarter of our best and
brightest are being lured by the siren
call of the money
machine instead of science engineering
or medicine they chose a career playing
with betting with other people's money
to get rich quick
very rich
and sometimes they take shortcuts
[Music]
my ancestors in greece talked about the
corrupting influence of power
and nothing has changed in these 3 000
years when you give control over massive
amounts of money to a few individuals
they will take advantage of that control
banks today are factoring in fines and
money laundering and all the rules that
they break into their cost of doing
business jp morgan is today coming out
and saying that bitcoin is not a
legitimate way of doing business banks
today are tied into a system that is
completely rigged to basically harvest
money from the entire global economy and
pump it into the hands of very few
[Music]
the existing banking system is cozy it's
captured the regulators it extracts
enormous value from society without
delivering anything in return and it is
parasitic in nature
the banks play a very pivotal role in an
economy you look at any successful
economy it has successful banks there's
a very close correlation with banking
profits and the economy as a whole
in medieval europe a banker who couldn't
repay depositors was hanged
today that same banker would get bailed
out paid bonuses and enjoy some tax
benefits too
to date no senior u.s banking executive
has been charged for selling the bad
loans that fueled the great recession
in december 2014 just six years after
the last banking crisis brought the
world to its knees
a congressman snuck a last-minute
provision written by citigroup into a
crucial funding bill
the provision allows the largest u.s
banks to once again make risky
derivatives bets with bank deposits
but no need to worry if the banks
implode again lost deposits must be paid
back
by u.s taxpayers
[Music]
today's financial innovators package
assets in ever more complex ways slicing
dicing securitizing always using someone
else's money they sell debt transfer
risks leverage bets
that's what they call innovation
when you're talking about financial
innovation bitcoin certainly uh is is a
very good example of innovation but
there's also been other innovations that
people
a bit closer to the world of finance
would
cite as good examples an example of that
would be the original swaps market from
there moving on to the credit default
swap it is an excellent example of
financial innovation but also if it's
used incorrectly it can create a lot of
problems as we've just seen
history teaches that the most
revolutionary and disruptive innovation
nearly always comes from the fringe not
from corporate cubicles
true innovators see the world
differently they see the big picture
creating new products and entire systems
that lead to new industries
steve jobs called them the square cogs
in round holes
it's unsurprising that new innovations
always come from a niche group of early
adopters because it is inherently very
hard for many people to realize the
benefits of new technologies
in 2011 most bitcoin community people
were
either people from the technology space
the geeks and hackers or people from the
traditional financial industry there are
even some bankers and hedge fund traders
using bikonika at that time as well
which was really surprising to me
a radical new idea is often met with
skepticism ridicule even hostility from
those who stand to lose the most from
its success
case in point
the automobile
in the late 19th century carl benz and
others built the first cars contraptions
that could threaten the stagecoach and
railroad industries these self-propelled
vehicles or road trains would certainly
scare horses injure people and damage
roads
cars the railroad barons said were just
too dangerous
and to protect us they used their power
to pass a law in 1865 it required every
automobile in england to observe a four
mile per hour speed limit and to be
operated by a crew of three a driver an
engineer and a flag man
this heroic flagmen walked in front of
the car to warn fellow citizens of the
coming danger
the railroad tycoons the lawmakers the
self-appointed gatekeepers used
regulation to stifle innovation
but they didn't invent the flagman he's
been around for a long time
for centuries very few could read books
were copied by hand the people in
control political and religious leaders
wanted to keep it that way and they
greeted johann gutenberg's printing
press with licensing laws publishing
bans
taxes
in some parts of the world printing was
a crime punishable by death
after all they were just protecting us
from dangerous ideas
before the printing press there were an
estimated 30 000 books in all of europe
50 years later there were 10 million
as gutenberg's invention flourished the
dark ages withered progress couldn't be
stopped
but the flag man never stops trying
his master set him loose on each of
these innovations because they
threatened someone's profits
someone's control
[Music]
but remember this is a story about money
what if a technological innovation
allowed anyone in the world to be their
own bank
to create a currency free from taxes and
banking fees
the u.s constitution forbids citizens
from printing or minting their own
currency
competing with or undercutting reliance
on the u.s dollar
in 1998 bernard von notthaus decided to
test the resolve of the federal
government
the liberty dollar was available in gold
silver platinum and copper
it was available in three forms
both in specie in other words gold and
silver
in paper as warehouse recedes and in
digital form
obviously the government didn't like it
they arrested me and convicted me
of counterfeiting fraud and conspiracy
and i'm currently awaiting
22 years
sentence in federal prison
[Music]
lesson
learned at a hacker's convention in
another one there was a young
hacker there
who used the alias of
satoshi nakamoto
and he talked to a friend of mine and he
identified
the liberty dollar and me as inspiring
him to create a new currency
bernard von notthaus's arrest for
creating private money may also have
inspired bitcoin's inventor to keep a
lower profile publishing the invention
under an alias
and vanishing
part of me is interested to know like
who satoshi is
maybe that's part of the mystique of the
story it's completely irrelevant to the
functioning of bitcoin because we have
the the
code to read
but it would be kind of fun to know
who is
archimedes
who is
euclid
we don't know
we don't know
if euclid was one person or multiple
people and you know what it doesn't
matter
euclidean geometry works whether i know
who euclid was or not whether euclid was
a moral and good person or whether he
was a corrupt plutocrat and a bastard
science and mathematics have
essential
truth that stands alone irrespective of
its inventors and irrespective of their
motives
well
bitcoin is a system based on
mathematical truths and these
mathematical truths stand alone
we can read the source code in bitcoin
and understand it and it will be true
whether satoshi nakamoto is a man
a woman a collection of individuals a
government agency or aliens from the
future
bitcoin is digital currency and computer
software
capital b bitcoin is the shared code
that creates a global payment network
using computers connected to the
internet
bitcoins are virtual currency digital
money created stored and exchanged on
that network but unlike virtual dollars
created by a banker this new currency
was created with math by an anonymous
inventor
bitcoin is an open source software
protocol like much of the code
supporting the internet and email
open source means anyone everyone can
use the protocol no one person or
company can control it every change to
the software is public open and
transparent
the code was first developed by satoshi
then there were dozens now hundreds of
programmers constantly collaborating to
improve bitcoin's features and security
so what makes bitcoin a breakthrough
it tackles an ancient human dilemma and
solves a computer science problem
any shared information or data can be
flawed corrupted
anything can be faked
how do we know that what we're receiving
can be trusted
in our traditional mindset it's very
important to know who is behind this
currency because their reputation is
significant in knowing that our funds
and the true wealth is actually safe
in finance we rely on trusted third
parties like banks credit card companies
remittance services they keep track of
money as it moves from one account to
another and they charge us handsomely
for it we trust that their digital
ledgers of credits and debits balance
a financial system that cuts out these
middlemen could be faster cheaper
and more secure
but bitcoin is digital music and movies
are easily pirated copied stolen how can
a digital currency retain value if
anyone can make a million copies
the answer is at the core of satoshi's
invention
a bitcoin is not a file on a computer
it's an entry in the publicly
distributed database called the
blockchain
just as the medici kept a ledger of
credits and debits
today's banks record each transaction as
a plus and minus in their ledgers now we
call them databases
bank accounts are replaced by a digital
wallet that you alone controlled
bitcoin's ledger is the blockchain a
record of every bitcoin in existence and
every bitcoin transaction ever made it
always balances because no bitcoin ever
leaves it
when a bitcoin is sent from one digital
wallet to another what they are really
sending is control over that part of the
database
code that is a unique key for the new
owner as the network processes
transactions it constantly synchronizes
the one ledger across the global network
each computer or bitcoin miner has a
complete and identical copy
and because the blockchain is public it
cannot be controlled by any one person
or computer
owners of the bitcoin mining computers
are rewarded with new bitcoins for
processing transactions and keeping the
network secure
[Music]
in other words the bitcoin network
replaces banks and bankers
today the combined computing power of
this global network is greater than the
500 biggest super computers combined
times 10 000
and because every transaction is
verified and recorded by the network a
bitcoin cannot be forged digital
currency cannot be debased with cheap
metals or printed by the billion at will
too much currency can unleash a monster
skyrocketing prices trillion dollar
bills that can't buy a loaf of bread
there's a big movement in the us
demanding that the fed be audited so we
can find out what they're doing
nobody really knows how many dollars are
in existence for example ben bernanke
created several trillions of dollars
over the last several years but nobody
really knows where they landed
at any time for any reason the central
banks can print as much money as they
want they call it fancy things like
quantitative easing and when they do
that it makes the dollars or euros or
yen that you and i have worth less so if
the world starts using bitcoin as their
their currency it can't be controlled by
central bankers or politicians
remember central banks create money to
boost the economy and try to pull it
back out before inflation heats up but
no one knows how much magic money global
banks are creating to boost their
profits with questionable loans
bitcoin is completely the opposite it's
totally transparent you know exactly how
many exists
the computer code behind bitcoin has a
built-in brake pedal cutting the
creation of bitcoins in half every four
years
this ensures a transparent controlled
scarcity
and ultimately limits the total number
of bitcoins to 21 million
no lobbyist no politician no banker can
create more
or change the mathematical rules
dictating their creation
advancing accountability uh and that's
something i think is most exciting about
bitcoin and the technology behind it is
not so much that it will supplant the
dollar or that it will supplant
government itself
but that all of a sudden there's a
competitor to government and the
government itself now needs to look over
its shoulder more than it did
this new digital currency can be
purchased online with a credit card or
in person with cash
and it has the five key characteristics
of money but is it a store of value
is it stable or will it diminish over
time like a commodity rented useless or
a crop that fails
the ultimate power of a cryptocurrency
is unleashed by mainstream adoption and
an ever-growing volume of transactions
with bitcoin
the currency has been created much more
slowly than other currencies and the
effect of that has been to turn it into
what is essentially a speculative asset
if you ask a lot of bitcoin enthusiasts
whether they're spending the currency
they're not they're sitting on it and
waiting for the price to go up it isn't
a currency if you don't use it to pay
people
the point is the average person is quite
happy to walk into a bar and hand over
you know a five dollar note in order to
get a drink
so you've got to realize that most
people are happy with the money system
they have
if most people are happy with cash
they're in love with plastic
in the u.s two-thirds of in-person sales
are done with debit or credit cards
that plastic is a 60 year old technology
created by a middleman
never designed for the internet
each transaction requires personal data
like your name and address
credit card databases are regularly
hacked
with fraudulent purchases charged to
your account
criminals buy and sell stolen credit
cards by the thousands in dark corners
of the internet
in some parts of london one third of all
online credit card transactions are
fraudulent
card issuers don't hold you responsible
for fraud but protection comes with a
price two to four percent in fees that's
50 billion dollars a year the issue with
credit cards from a merchant's
perspective is there's a lot of risk if
they take a credit card there might be a
chargeback there might be fraudulent
purchases in fact there's hundreds of
billions of dollars every year in
fraudulent purchases
a bitcoin purchase is done for pennies
but there are no protections if you lose
your passwords or are fooled into paying
the wrong person you can never get your
money back it is like digital cash for a
seller this means no chargeback risks
for an e-commerce company like expedia
or overstock cutting credit card fees
can double their profit margin
[Music]
you could not miss the point more
effectively than by thinking of bitcoin
as a currency and payment network that
will make shopping easier for the first
world bitcoin is about everything else
everywhere else
there are 2.5 billion people without a
bank account
with bitcoin a mobile phone with an
internet connection is now a bank with
access to the global marketplace
what happens when bitcoin services and
infrastructure and bitcoin wallets and
payment processes start going into these
countries these people will be able to
gain benefits from trade where they
could not previously these people will
be able to
send money home uh international
remittance which is one of the major
pain points of the current financial
system
here if i send a hundred dollars with
banks going to cost me 20 percent
western union is going to cost 10
percent uh other options that are
competing western union still going to
be about 5
and if you are sending to really remote
areas it's going to be anywhere between
15 and 30 percent
so in terms of money movement says it's
going to be a game changer using bitcoin
you do not need a bank account you just
need an internet connection and a wallet
to get set up it's a tool to give people
an access into the global ecosystem and
give them a promise for an economic
future and specifically
provide a way for them to not be
dependent on a government that could
shut down their bank accounts or even
could go into their bank accounts and
take out finances
goldman sachs came out with a report and
they basically looked at if you were to
replace all transactions globally so fx
bank to bank transactions
with the bitcoin protocol and still
charging one percent mind you it would
save the global economy 200 billion so
not million 200 billion dollars a year
in saved transaction costs which
ultimately goes back into the hands of
the consumer
an international wire transfer can take
up to four days
yet the internet allows us to instantly
and globally share text pictures videos
anything digital
why not money money which we now know
only exists as digits in a bank's
database
wouldn't it be great if you could send
bitcoin transactions just simply via
tweet
for example you would say at
the end of money
one dollar worth of bitcoin
and so we built just that all you have
to do is hashtag it with tippercoin
press send and our twitter bot will
process the transactions notify you and
give you a link and this will allow you
to either withdraw your bitcoins or send
it to someone else
with bitcoin you can send one dollar or
one million dollars worth of value
anywhere in the world you can do it for
free or you pay the bitcoin network fee
which is still just around a penny and
there's nothing that the big banks or
politicians can do to stop it
a cryptocurrency that can only be
created and transferred with computer
networks may be the next step of the
digital revolution
the rise of machines
self-driving cars
drones
robots that rely less and less on humans
what i
often think is that the future of
bitcoin or digital currency from you
know a broader perspective
is really about machine to machine
payments
so by the time you have an unmanned taxi
driving you around new york and then
going to power up at an unmanned power
station
or going to get repairs at an unmanned
auto shop you'll see the machine to
machine payments done with some sort of
digital currency
[Music]
[Music]
we actually built this world that we
live in over the last two or three
hundred years we've made some mistakes
we've learned to make things better
the idea that there's some magic key
that if you just sort of stop doing a
few things that there'll be this perfect
order that will settle is a very
childish ideological delusion in my
opinion but that is not to say
that bitcoin isn't an exciting thing
it's a terrifically exciting thing
but we have to try and engage with it
with working minds not with magical
thinking people are suggesting
that it's going to be another world
currency
rivalry in the dollar or the euro or the
yen i think that's
not going to happen
i prefer to trust the banks or the
central government compared to the
bitcoin is because someone's accountable
whereas with the bitcoin it's completely
deregulated
there's no central control
there's no one held accountable
it is a free float it's purely demand
and supply driven
so clearly this is
not a currency currencies don't behave
like this but what this is is a high
risk speculative commodity
so for the entrepreneurs the bankers the
governments and everyone else studying
and watching bitcoin all i have to say
is that there will probably be a lot of
volatility in an upward trajectory and
to buckle up
criminals scam artists bad actors are
drawn to any kind of money like a moth
to a flame
silk road was a marketplace that was
online it existed in the underground web
now this marketplace allowed people to
sell things that were illegal to
governments
fake ids
pirated music
bibles in north korea
are crypto currencies inherently bad
or just the newest tool to acquire the
forbidden
porn is illegal in iran it was a few
percent percentage points of sales on
silk road was to sell porn to iranians
now a much broader one that gets a lot
of press with regards to silk road is
drugs
i've been doing research over the past
couple of years into the online drug
marketplaces in the darknet using tor
and bitcoin as technologies
to enable illicit drug transactions
we did a global survey of drug users
and we had over 20 000 people respond to
that and the majority of those people
were buying traditionally illicit drugs
ecstasy cannabis
the fbi brought down silk road it
certainly hasn't stopped the trading of
illicit drugs online
a lot of people want to criticize
bitcoin for being used for for illegal
things or a list of things but if you
look at it the most popular currency in
the entire world for doing bad things is
the us dollar
if you think of bitcoin as a platform
instead of a currency then you really
begin to see the potential it has
the ledger which cannot be forged it
cannot be changed and the universe
accepted is genius there will be bitcoin
technology forever and it'll have
applications for years to come creating
a secure global payment system may just
be the beginning
patents contracts land titles proof of
ownership can be baked into bitcoin
securely held in the public ledger
i read up more about bitcoin i played
with the source code i built some things
that i realized this is actually a very
very powerful protocol it's not just the
currency but it's actually programmable
money
the digital age has fundamentally
changed the world we have embraced
digitized music
film medical records communications the
internet
the free exchange of information and
currency can fuel revolutions
help in a disaster
but our money is shackled to the 20th
century
manipulated by governments and banks
the champions of bitcoin ask us to
imagine payments without a middleman
investments without a broker loans
without a bank insurance without an
underwriter charity without a trustee
escrow without an agent betting without
a bookie record keeping without an
accountant global secure
nearly instant and free
is it fantasy or the future of money and
commerce
[Music]
i love bitcoins i'm really into bitcoin
well satoshi nakamoto that's the name i
love to say and we don't know much about
him but he came to save the day
if you don't know what a bitcoin is
right usually the way people describe it
is uh digital cash
it's money for the internet
of bitcoin as you're going into the old
blockchain of bitcoin i know you're
going to rain gonna rain people are like
oh i love my bank i'm like really you
ask a banker you know what's two plus
two he's like well i can tell you but
there's a fee
down the road it will be told about the
death of old mount gox about traders
trading alter coins and miners mining
now bitcoin is a new technology i like
to say it's banking lights
all
of the
[Music]
convenience know you're going to rain
gonna rain until everybody knows
everybody knows you know when i go
online and i buy like i don't know a
pair of socks if i pay with a credit
card
i'm just buying socks
right if i buy those socks with bitcoin
it's a revolution
i am sticking it to the man
[Music]
lord pass me some more
there's always people who are not ready
to get into the new technology you know
like when the internet came out there
was people going nah
i don't think this is gonna be
popular and then email came out and
people like nah
this isn't gonna catch on
and now bitcoin comes out people like i
don't think i'm like aren't you sick of
being wrong
get on this train you know
[Applause]